coming.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
came to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
in migration as a muaji
in the same year that the battle of
happened.
Now it's differed amongst the scholars
of
scholars of and amongst the Muslim
historians with regards to the exact
date and the exact year of the battle of
some view it in the sixth year after
Hijra. Others view it in the seventh
year after Hijra.
However, we know for a fact that Abu
arrived
during or right immediately after the
battle of as a matter of fact he arrived
so closely
during the time of the battle of that
he was considered amongst those who were
given of the spoils of war during
that battle
he accepted Islam
And he came from a land known as do. And
that is why he is referred to as Adosi.
He is from the land of dose.
When he made hijra, he came with his
mother. But his mother did not
immediately accept Islam.
She accepted Islam later on. And perhaps
a time will come when we will mention
the story of his mother's acceptance
of Islam.
However,
when he first arrived, he was very poor
and he arrived to a
sofa. What is a sofa? A sofa in the
Arabic language literally translates to
the canopy. The canopy. A sofa is a is a
canopy or a small ceiling that is placed
or put up using date palm branches
as a kind of cover to provide some kind
of shade and some kind of shelter
from rain and so forth.
And when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam first arrived in Medina,
he was still praying towards Beth
Maktis. So his prayer was to the general
direction of the west
and he continued to pray in that
direction for 16 months
desiring to be directed to the Kaa as
his
as hisl
because that is the of the prophets and
messengers of all the prophets and
messengers
and faith. facing towards be makdis was
an innovation that was later contrived
by the people of the book. However,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made it so
that he could face both at the same time
when he was in Mecca. So when he was in
Mecca he would stand facing towards the
west with thea between him and
make salah. However, when he made hijra
now he had to turn to one or the other.
And so he desired that hisl be restored
to that of Ibraim.
And so
at the very front of the masjid, the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
masid was long. It was elongated, kind
of a rectangle, if you will. And at
the very front where the imam would
stand,
there would be that sofa. There would be
that canopy that would shade over the
imam. And the rest of the masid was
open. It was open air. The it had no
ceiling.
And so when the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam had the direction of his kibla
back to Mecca,
he then came to the other end of the
masjid,
built a new sofa there and that became
the place where he prayed. Well, the
very very back we still have that old
canopy where he used to stand. That is a
sofa. That is the canopy. And people
that would arrive
in Mecca in Medina having migrated
while they get on their feet while
they establish themselves. Those who
didn't have a place to go, they didn't
have any family members in Medina, they
didn't have any connections, they didn't
have any real wealth, they would stay
there in a sua. And so those people were
referred to as
they were known for their patience. They
were known for their steadfastness,
their unwavering support of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. And
they have a specific virtue with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that others do
not have. And that is why the scholars
when they mention the the merits of any
particular companion this is one of the
merits that they will mention. They will
say for instance he was from
and you know along with he was in
for instance or he was in the battle of
or what have you and this would be
mentioned amongst his merits. And so
Abu
only spent
a little bit over four years with the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam in most
generous estimates. A little over four
years. However, we see that
narrates a huge majority or a huge bulk
of the narrations and the sunnah of our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and some
people they are unclear about this.
How is it that a man that
only spent four years with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam narrates all
of these narrations whilst others from
amongst his companions even his own
wives such as
or others who specialize in collecting
his narrations are not even close to the
amount that he narrates. This is the
question even
asked this very same question and
said to Abu.
[Silence]
She said to him, "Oh Abu, all of these
narrations that we've never heard of,
you have heard of yet we all were
sitting with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam." Is there
I mean you saw the same things that we
saw and you heard the same things that
we heard. How is it that you have so
much more narrations? Now this is not
that she is accusing him
of making anything up. This never
happened of course and none of the
companions ever accused
of such a thing. But the question is how
did this happen? How is it so
disproportionately
to your side the amount of narrations
that you narrate of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam? And he said
to her
[Silence]
He said you were to an extent
occupied,
preoccupied with you know making
yourself presentable for the prophet
sallall.aii
and you know
making yourself the best wife that you
can for him. And so this preoccupied you
to an extent and it has to. As for me,
absolutely nothing preoccupied me from
him. Not even not even work or
poverty or hunger.
In other narrations, he mentions.
I used to continuously be with the
prophet sallall.aii
wasam every moment that I could as long
as I had something to eat as long as I
was able to keep myself
nourished enough to follow him saiam.
So we see that Abu Huray when when you
envision Abu, I want you to envision a
man that from the moment that he arrived
in Medina until the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam passed away, he was literally
in the masid.
Every single time that he saw the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
leave his house come out lead salah
anything go anywhere take a walk
anywhere abu would be with him
and the prophet sallai wasallam made dua
for
this exact thing there's a narration in
that and two other companions
made dua for one for one another. And so
they said, "Let us make dua and each of
us ask for something and the other two
say a mean." And so each of them asked
for something and Abu Hur then asked
made his dua and as he made his dua the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam passed by
and joined their gathering. after the
first two. And so he said,
[Silence]
that Abu said in his turn, "Oh Allah, I
ask you for the same thing that my two
companions asked you for
and I also ask you for knowledge that
will never be forgotten." And the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
said along with him. It said that he was
born 21 years before the hijra of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and he
later went on to pass away in the year
59 after hijra in the most correct
estimates which would place his age at
how old?
59 and se 59 and 21 80 years old very
old
and this also plays a huge part in the
amount of narrations that he narrated
tomorrow we will conclude our discussion
about Abu and continue on
yes
[Arabic recitation]
called
would this be equated as the hijra from
Mecca
Now it is it is equal to the hij from
Mecca. however he is not ashi but
anyone who has made hijra from his land
from anywhere to medina is considered to
be a muaji.
Now,
yeah, because there's a general
division, right? So, it's muajir and one
or the other. Now,